Speaker 1: To prove that this white
Christian nationalism isn't just a
fringe element in America today. I want to play
you this Steve Bannon clip where he has this
this dingdong on. I mean, Steve
Bannon is mainstream Republicanism
and there's a melding of politics and religion
in a way that we've not seen it yet before.
Where they're blending religion and politics and
conspiracy. To try to tap in to that emotional,
spiritual belief system of the base. And here
is Steve Bannon talking with this gentleman.
About spiritual warfare. Again, I'm
I come from this religious tradition,
evangelical white Christian nationalism. And
there's there's a there's a scripture that's
commonly repeated about we fight not against
flesh and blood, but against the principalities
and powers and spiritual wickedness in high
places. I was raised in a church that believes
there's actual demonic and angel warfare invisibly
taking place all around you, that if you can see
into the spirit world, you'd be able to witness.
It's like the movie Constantine or something.
This is what I was taught. This is what
I believed until I started reading books.
And this is what Steve Bannon is
peddling as a mainstream Republican
with a large platform. Watch this clip.
Speaker 3: Are we in a spiritual war?
Speaker 4: 1,000%. I that that's exactly why
we're doing this. I think that, you know,
says in the Bible, even in a battle isn't
against flesh and blood. And I can tell you,
I come to D.C. quite often. And today we were
worshiping actually on the rotunda floor inside of
the Capitol. And you can feel it, man. It's like
a real it's a real battle. It's a real spiritual
battle that we're in. And I think it's time.
Speaker 3: To say you can feel
it. What do you mean by that?
Speaker 4: You can feel. I can feel that things
have changed. I'm actually really optimistic.
Speaker 3: Tell people that
because they need to hear that.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I am. I am. I mean,
we've been doing stuff. Listen, we had the
we've had the largest gathering in the church
in Washington, D.C. for the last three years
in a row. We've had it on the National Mall.
And it's been it's been difficult. You
know, the last two years, especially
not just the permitting and the process and
jump through all the hoops, but spiritually,
it's it's I've thought a lot of resistance.
Speaker 3: There's like an a there's like
there's having it as I have there's a
way there's a meanness in this town.
Speaker 4: But something happened with this
whole regime change in the house and I don't
even know. I'm still like processing it.
But today I was walking through the Capitol
with my guitar. We are worshiping, we're
singing. No one was stopping us. There was
no red tape. It's definitely a new day here.
Speaker 3: You can feel it. We only got a
couple of minutes. I need people because I try
to tell people this. There was there was like
this heavy blanket. There was something on top
of this is a spiritual force that was pressing
things down. It's not all the way lifted. Yeah,
but you definitely you can definitely feel that
there's an energy here that was not here before.
Speaker 4: Yeah, there's a crack. There's. There's
starting to be. I feel like we're coming
into a season where it's like there's some
light breaking through, you know, and it's
enough to actually give a lot of hope. And,
you know, we've had it. We've been meeting
with members of Congress, senators, and
everyone has this kind of expectation about this.
Speaker 1: And lest you think that this is just a
one off, Steve Bannon needs to fill some air time
and create some content for the base. I submit to
you this Newsmax interview same day, likely within
just a few minutes of this taking place, where
Newsmax interviews some wingnut who's talking
about, again, linking politics and spiritual
warfare that ancient gods are now attacking. It is
the same network that Republicans are are all in a
twist about AT&T no longer distributing. Is airing
this nonsense again. Mainstream meme linking
politics and spiritual warfare. Yeah. Yes. What?
You know, even it's behind cancel culture. It's
behind wokeism. It's behind what's happening
to our politics. Even Supreme Court decisions,
even like the last three Supreme Court decisions
that linked up with marriage or sexuality, all of
them took place on an exact same date linked to a
pagan in Chicago just a little while back. Chris,
you know, the president had a gathering at the
White House basically, you know, called the
Respect for Marriage Act, supposedly. But it's
basically striking down marriage as we know it
on. And he lit up the White House in the colors
of the rainbow. Well, there is one of these gods
I speak about, the dark trinity, and that was in
ancient times. It's back. One of them is called
the Transformer. And this is a this is a god
or a spirit from ancient times that actually
said it has the power. It's a she has the power to
turn a man into a woman, a woman into man. Blend
the lines of gender, blend the lines of male
and female. While it's happening right now,
she actually had an ancient priesthood that
dressed up with men dressing up as women. This is
what is being championed by the government right
now. It's champion of our children. She actually
had some of her priests surgically transitioned.
While this spirit is in our culture. And I was
going to give you a quick taste as we I'm sure we
all talk. But here's the thing. What she actually
was the gods got a parade. So we have parades.
She paraded men dressed up as women. We got it
back. She actually claimed the one time of the
year for possession of the culture. And you know
what? The time was? June. So it's back. Also had
one side particular was the sign of the rainbow.
So this is big. It's affecting all of us. And
yes, it's affecting the culture. And as you said,
it's happening in rapid, rapid progression
and it's accelerating even to this day.
So what? That beard with the face stapled to it
is talking about is linked to this kind of stuff.
Spiritual warfare. Because there's a statue.
And they're linking politics and the fight
ahead. And I believe what they're attempting
to do is really connect to the base and the
conspiracy elements that surround this particular
faith tradition. And it's being mainstreamed by
Steve Bannon and Jason Ripert and whoever
this knucklehead is, it's dangerous. You
need to be paying attention to this because this
is only going to get worse before it gets better